d'abord vous savez vous me connaissez un
peu je ne crois pas aux communautés je
ne connais que la communauté nationale
donc c'est un premier sujet de discorde
moi je ne connais que des citoyens
français de confession juive
éventuellement ou pas et je sais comme
ça que je me considère c'est comme ça
que je me vis
à l'époque dont vous parlez dans les
années 60 70 le premier à s'être élevé
contre ce que vous analysez fort bien
s'appelle quand même claude lévi strauss
vous avez vu je le cite c'est pas
n'importe qui
donc moi je me situe dans les spas
modeste de claude lévi-strauss ailleurs
ton beaucoup d'autres sujets je pense
effectivement qu'à partir des années 70
les non pas la communauté juive les
dirigeants de la communauté les gens du
crif le comme le grand rabbin
aujourd'hui à une corse ya tous ces gens
oui on choisit le communautarisme
meilleur exemple c'est le fameux dîner
du crif où les gouvernants et le
président la république lui-même sont
sommés de s'expliquer sur la politique
18 juillet les vous mêmes j'avais un
journaliste jamais même pas en tant que
journaliste jamais et ça m'a toujours
choqué d'ailleurs d'autres juifs
célèbrent et qui n'ont pas du tout mes
idées ont été choqués je me souviens
qu'à la main a protesté contre ce genre
de dîner - oui je pense que là les
dirigeants encore une fois je ne parle
pas des juifs des français de confession
juive je parle des dirigeants les
dirigeants ont opté pour le
communautarisme et ont ouvert la voie à
d'autres comme une attaque d'ailleurs
vous vous souvenez ce que je sais que
vous me lisez attentivement que je l'ait
déjà dénoncé dans le suicide français ça
ne me dérange pas d'être en opposition
avec les dirigeants d'une communauté qui
sont
complètement en décalage en déphasage
avec une com avec avec les ch avec le
peuple c'est exactement le même critère
le même commentaire la même évolution
que dans le reste de la france le
décalage entre les dirigeants et
le peuple si vous voulez moi je pense
que là par exemple dans les attaques que
je subis de la part du grand rabbin de
france du président du crif si vous
voulez il y a au coeur ce décalage c'est
à dire que eux m'attaque parce qu'ils
ont très bien compris que je dénonçais
ce que vous avez analysé c'est à dire
cette évolution communautariste c'est
parce que je
sais je sais bien je sais bien alors que
alors que les les français de confession
juive ne voit qu'eux ils ont été à
chasser de la seine saint denis par
les avancées islamique
[Musique]